does the quality of meat affect your
body I.E does it need to be grass-fed
slash organic I do not eat grass-fed
meat very often I don't really like how
it tastes compared to not grass-fed meat
what I don't eat is aged meat aged meat
gives me digestive problems if I eat
aged meat my stomach hurts almost 15 or
20 minutes after eating it I've got a
very sensitive digestion but histamine
intolerance is something that's fairly
common on a carnivorous diet and
histamine intolerance is when you react
basically to aged meat that's a very
simplified way but that's how I'm going
to describe it so I eat lamb and bison
which are generally lower in histamine
and aren't aged as long and I eat beef
from better fed whom I love that's
mostly where I get my meat and then
white oak pastures has unaged beef and
so does Billy dough so if you start the
carnivore diet and you're having like
urgency issues or bloating after you eat
meat it could be because your body
doesn't like aged meat so I tell
everyone to eat unaged meat at least at
the beginning so lamb and bison you're
pretty much good at the grocery store
and beef you have to go searching for it
from the companies that I just mentioned
[Music]